si pensamos en algo como 2 elevado al
cubo podemos verlo como tomar 3 2 que se
multiplican 2 x 2 por 2 y de igual
manera podemos tomar un 1 y
multiplicarlo por estos 2 que se
multiplican tres veces usemos esta
definición que por supuesto nos dará
igual a 8 ahora con base en esta
definición que acabamos de hacer cuál
será 2 a la segunda potencia pues será 1
por 2 x 2
y uno por dos por dos va a ser igual a
cuatro cuánto será 2 a la 1 puede ser a
1 por 2 una vez nada más este 2 que es
igual a 2
ahora hagámonos una pregunta interesante
con base en esta definición de lo que es
un exponente cuánto será 2 elevado a la
potencia 0 los invito a que piensen un
poco en ello como define esto la
comunidad matemática de manera que sea
consistente con lo que acabamos de ver
pues pues como acabamos de ver la
exponencia acción inicia con un 1 que
multiplica a la base 0 veces así que no
voy a multiplicar ningún 2 solo me voy a
quedar con el 1 tiene sentido esto de
que 2 a la 0 sea igual a 1
bueno pensamos esto de otra forma usemos
otra base se me ocurre el 3 y puedo
decir que 3 elevado a la cuarta potencia
es igual a 3 por 3 x 3 por 3 que es
igual a 81 de hecho permítanme
escribirlo esto es igual a 81 si digo 3
a la 3 es igual a tres por tres por tres
que es igual a 27 ahora 3 al cuadrado es
igual a 93 a la 1 va a ser igual a 3 y
aquí vemos que hay un patrón estamos
disminuyendo el exponente de uno en uno
pero qué pasa con el valor bueno en el
caso del exponente 4 que pasa a 3 el 81
pasa a 27 el 81 se divide entre 3 lo que
tiene sentido ya que estamos quitando un
3 que estábamos multiplican dividimos
entre 3 para pasar de 81 a 27 ahora
dividimos entre 3 nuevamente cada
es que disminuye el exponente en una
unidad finalmente dividimos de nuevo
entre 3 para pasar de 9 a 3
ahora basados en esto cuanto creen que
valga 3 a la potencia 0 pues el patrón
es que dividamos entre la base cada vez
que disminuye la potencia en 1 así que
nuevamente dividimos entre 3 siguiendo
la lógica de este patrón por lo que 3
dividido entre 3 pues nos da 1 de nuevo
sé que esto no es algo intuitivo que
cualquier cosa elevada a la potencia
cero va a ser igual a 1 pero es así como
la comunidad matemática ha definido esto
porque tiene mucho sentido ya sea que
vean al exponente como uno que
multiplica a la base por sí misma el
número de veces indicado por el
exponente multiplicar el uno por dos
multiplicado tres veces
si seguimos este otro patrón en el que
cada vez que se disminuye en uno el
exponente vamos a dividir el valor entre
la base cualquiera de ambos métodos nos
llevará a la conclusión de que cualquier
número elevado a la potencia cero
siempre va a ser igual a uno digamos que
tenemos un número a y que este elevado a
la potencia cero esto siempre va a ser
igual a uno ahora tengo una pregunta
interesante para ustedes y digamos que
esto se cumple para todas a que sea
diferente de ser quiero que piensen en
esto que creen que sea cero elevado a la
potencia cero lo interesante de esto de
cero elevado a la potencia cero es que
van a tener una respuesta diferente con
cada método que acabamos de usar aquí
con la primera técnica un método nuestro
resultado será 1 y con la otra técnica
tenemos una división entre 0 lo cual es
una indeterminación así
y los dejaré meditando sobre los
misterios del 0 elevado a la potencia 0